Priscilla Presley
is now disputing the validity
of her daughter's will.
She was removed as a co-
trustee back in 2016
and replaced by Lisa Marie's children.
But Priscilla's lawyers now
say there were several issues
with the document.
They say Priscilla's name was mi
Lisa Marie signature doesn't loo
As you know, Lisa Marie is Elvis
Presley's only child.
She was laid to rest
at his Graceland estate earlier
this month.
Joining us now to talk about
this is CNN's
chief business correspondent, an
start anchor, Christine Romans.
So a living trust
is basically this form of a way
to control your assets
while you're still alive.
What does it mean?
What is the dispute here?
So the issue here is that Prisci
Presley didn't know in 2016 that
the trustees had been changed
upon the death of Lisa Marie.
It wasn't notarized.
That's one of the things
she's concerned about.
She wasn't alerted.
And that is required ironclad.
Part of this trust is
that she must be notified of any
to this document and she wasn't.
So that's why her lawyers
have petitioned the court
to see if this 2016 amendment
to her will is actually legal an
Wow. I mean it is.
How long could this take do this
I was looking at the Michael
Jackson estate
that took 12 years to settle.
And Michael Jackson was heavily
when he died.
And it was interesting to me,
by the time they settled that
Hollister gate,
it was profitable again.
It was like four times as profit
as it had been.
So you've got an estate here
that includes a 50% stake
in Elvis Presley Enterprises,
Graceland, the mansion, which Pr
at one time had said.
It is
Lisa Marie is
it is absolutely how to present
It will always be mine.
Graceland. It will always be.
And when it's no longer mine,
it will be my children's.
And that is that.
And now we are at the place
where her children are named in
this will as her trustees now.
And her own mother is disputing
So it's granddaughters
and a grandmother together
over the future
of what is a very complicated,
complicated fortune.
It's interesting that you mentio
Michael Jackson because,
you know, they have that connect
But also to me, when you look at
most of the folks who die,
a lot of them die in debt.
And then you guys are not spendi
quite often within months or yea
they end up
you know, the estates
just go up and down.
Elvis
Presley made much more money in
frankly, than he did in life.
You know,
that has been a brand that has b
you know, just sterling
Michael Jackson, Whitney Houston